[Music]
[Applause]
is Rex Ryan set to join us good to go
yes okay Sunday NFL Countdown premieres
this weekend at 10 Eastern on the
mothership Randy Moss Teddy brewski Adam
schefter Sam Ponder and Alex Smith is
going to be joining the lineup Rex Ryan
will be there on Sunday mornings as well
the former coach joins us on the program
let me start with a question I've been
asking all morning long who did you
learn more about last night the Lions or
the Chiefs
oh that's a good question Dad I think
I I know a lot about Detroit so I wasn't
surprised by their effort and the fact
they won the game
um
nobody wanted to play Detroit at the end
of last year they won eight and nine we
all know that but I think it was it was
great to watch him in front of a
national audience
at a tough place to play against the
best player in the world Patrick my home
so that was great but I wasn't surprised
by it
I think what we saw yesterday was how
much Kansas City needs Travis Kelsey
though they really need Travis Kelsey
and I think that's who they missed
obviously Chris Jones A lot's going to
be made about that and yeah he's one of
the best players in the league but
you know no matter how good you are you
can't win without players and I think we
saw that yesterday
um and not taking anything away from
Detroit because they earned that game I
mean hell Detroit should have been up
another score you know in that game had
had they not turned the ball over so
um you know it was a great game but we
got to get you know Kansas City has to
get Travis Kelsey back on the field and
hopefully Chris Jones follows
what would you say in the moment to uh
cadarius Tony when he has these drops
and then does that change do you say
anything to him today if you were his
head coach uh or last night what do you
say in the moment
well I think in a moment you you can't
lose the player you know but in a way
it's almost like this player has had so
many opportunities before an epic fail
with the Giants when they had them you
know he's always been a talented guy but
at some at some point you got to put a
foot in his butt and and say hey you're
either going to do it or you're not and
we don't have to play it and I I think
that's what's I I think it's reaching
that point but hell he had three or four
drops in that game and it was uh you
know hey some of the best players in the
world are walking the street nobody
cares all right and that could be him
you know you're either gonna get it done
you're a receiver you're paid to catch
some football and you know but it's you
know this isn't Little League where
you're like hey son you get it back you
get it back no you're paid to catch some
football and and that was an invisible
performance by him now with that being
said the guy missed a ton of time in
Camp you know with injuries so you can
kind of dismiss it a little bit but but
if it happens again it's time to look
for a different guy Mike Tirico late in
the game said that this win would have
an asterisk attached to it
do you agree
no
absolutely 100 no way in hell do I agree
with that
no way
you know it should have been an asterisk
that that guy was lined up in the back
view of the whole game the right tackle
that should have been the freaking
asterisk I mean that was ridiculous and
by the way look at the movement against
well that's called a false start you
should have called them for I mean he he
wasn't lined up they never had enough
players on the line of scrimmage all
right Andy's a false start every time
and the fact you got this Aiden
Hutchinson who by the way is an absolute
Beast like I get it you're trying to get
all the edge that that you want
but lining up in a backfield it just
looks stupid and and you allowed it that
that was that's something that might be
an asterisk there's no way the League's
gonna allow that to happen next week how
did they let that happen Rex how does
the head of officials not say to these
guys at halftime guys you're making
everybody look silly here
yeah I have no idea and I thought it was
great I think it was Terry McCauley that
was in the booth yeah and they they
protect each other well but he finally
just said no it's absolutely illegal and
good for him to do that I thought that
was great because most of those guys
don't have the guts are saying he
absolutely you know it was killing him
being an outstanding official it was
killing him and and that's that like
he's doing it for what to gain a huge
Advantage you know and I thought it was
interesting late in that game and almost
in the entire
uh from the second half on it seemed
like they had to ship Hutchinson anyway
you know so they were chipping them and
had a guy lined up in the backfield
um so I I disagree and I love Mike Trico
but I totally disagree with him there's
no asterisk here dude is part of it the
kid got hurt and and that's just the way
it is but you know what maybe this maybe
this matchup will meet again
one day and that would be interesting to
me that if I could see it because I
believe in Alliance I absolutely believe
in lies and it's not just the fact my
son coach is there I believe in him
I think Juan Taylor's uh asterisk was in
the backfield that's that's the asterisk
absolutely uh we're talking to uh Rex
Ryan absolutely
um are you on the Jets hype train
at no doubt no doubt and Dan all I am is
just basing it on 30 years coaching or
whatever it is this is the most talented
defensive team that Jets have ever had
at least certainly it was way more
talented than I had yeah and and we had
you know we led the league in defense
always had some of the best defenses we
never had this kind of talent they have
seven guys that can Rush the faster
second we were lucky to get two they
have seven guys that can rush the passer
they're great on the back end slash
Gardener's an outstanding player we get
it but so is read the other Corner they
got you know uh the linebacking cork can
can you know their run hit guys within
cover so I I just think
that this defense is absolutely loaded
oh and by the way they have Aaron
Rodgers a quarterback like like no this
is it and Garrett Wilson is
uncomfortable like so this is gonna be
you know outstanding and here's the
other thing can we finally give Woody
Johnson a little credit I hate the fact
everybody's quick to oh Woody Johnson
the problem Woody Johnson has never been
the problem never been the problem with
the New York Jets all right he sat back
and said you know what I'm gonna go for
it I'm I'm doing I'm gonna give my coach
every opportunity to win
and in a win at all so what's he do
whatever it takes go get Aaron Rodgers
and that's what he did and by the way he
just paid seven million dollars to a
backup running back Dalvin cook you
don't think this guy wants to win and
win right now he's doing it for you New
York and now it's time to you know to
collect on it a little bit and you know
why in the heck would Aaron Rodgers play
in the preseason because Dan he's been
horrible the first week of the regular
season the last couple of years horrible
I think it was against Minnesota uh I
believe I know the Saints one year they
look terrible and so you know what let's
get that game out of the way and they
did and it took us yes but they got that
game out of the way he ought to be ready
to roll and you know and by the way
they're we're gonna find out week one
against the Buffalo Bills I mean an
amazing football team right here with
the my favorite player in the National
Football League and Josh Allen I what a
matchup this is going to be a dream
matchup and we're fortunate as hell
because we got it you know Monday night
ESPN has that game so we're I mean we
are super stoked for it but uh
but what what an opportunity for for the
for the Jets and the Jets you know look
I love buffalo I love their owner Terry
pagula
um
but this is the Jets moment and and I
truly believe it
Michael uh uh Irvin said yesterday that
uh he could see Dion maybe coaching the
Cowboys one day
what do you make of that oh that would
be great
that would be fantastic you just got to
bring his son with him
[Laughter]
but uh
you know I I spent some time when when
Dion took the job
uh at Jackson State I went there in the
spring and
you know his passion and love for his
players and and genuine love and concern
for his players I think resonates you
know
with those guys and there's no BS to
Dion
this this is a guy I I was fortunate to
coach him
when he was 37 and 38 years old or
something like that but he was one of
the greatest teammates I've ever seen
and that's just who Deion Sanders is and
if he chooses to go coach in the
National Football League so be it
that'll be great bring some great
coaches with you or whatever but he's
you know
he's he's a special special guy and it
was huge to see that win you know
against TCU here here's a team that went
to the National Championship everybody's
making fun of what Dion did no Dion went
to a team that had no players
and he said we're the power five School
and this is the worst recruiting job by
any coaching staff maybe ever
and he's like no you you got to earn the
right to play for me and he got rid of
him replaced 53 players or whatever it
was and yeah it's not a traditional way
of doing things it's not the way he
wants to do things
but it's it's what he had to do to be
competitive he's not going to bring
himself and his sons over there to not
have success so he he tried to put the
best team that he possibly could do on
the field and that's why he did what he
did
good to talk to you again rex have a
great season and uh our best to uh the
NFL Countdown crew I appreciate it Dan
always a pleasure that's Rex Ryan had
some interesting things to say I didn't
know that he had gone down to Jackson
State when Dion was down there and he'll
be part of the countdown crew coming up
this weekend